I haven't made any public comment on it
and I'm not going to start on this show
everybody has a timeline of the
that you have to come to vote but I
think that it's likely to be decided
before then and I probably will decide
along with most others I think it's
howard dean who suggested the end of
june if i'm not mistaken
I'm from Maine I represented main in the
Senate but I'm now a resident of New
York primarily I when I left the Senate
i remarried a young children my children
go to school here so you're sort of
that's what you end up as a voting
taxpaying citizen when obama won the
main carcasses i got a bunch of letters
and calls from people because they and i
thought i'd be a again a super delegate
for maine I've been a super delegate for
me since I love to sign it and they said
well Obama won in Maine so you should
vote for Obama then Clinton won in New
York and I got a few calls from Clinton
people saying well you live in New York
you ought to vote for Clinton because
she won New York and then the Democratic
National Committee announced yes in fact
I would be a dog soup delegate from New
York so then I started getting calls
from my Obama friends making a
completely different argument and both
sides argument have shifted over time if
you say dude should you should I vote in
accordance with the majority in the
state that's New York then I would vote
for Clinton should I vote for the
majority in my congressional district
should I vote for who wins the popular
vote nationwide should that popular vote
include or exclude Florida which is
likely to be deterring factored who with
I mean each of these has an argument in
of itself by guess my feeling is I feel
much like i did in the Senate when I had
to advise it consent on presidential
nominations the Constitution doesn't
define what you do so i think i should
use my best judgment taking into account
and giving great weight to the way
others have voted and there are as i
just mentioned numerous iterations of
that you can look at one of several
factors including the number delegates
they have one through the elective
process but in the end making a judgment
which my conscience and judgment tells
me is the person who will best serve the
nation and as a democrat who will be
most likely to be a
do
if I did I wouldn't tell you because I
would of course defeat the purpose of
any mediation and I don't so I'm not
giving any secrets from you and I don't
think it's likely to happen I think it's
all going to work out before them I not
not you're not a reporter in the
strictest sense but you know the press
has an interest in controversy keeping
it going and devising scenarios that
suggest a conflict right down to the
last minute of the last hour of the last
roll call at the convention and maybe
beyond but I think reality is to the
contrary I think it is likely to be
resolved not too long after the last
primary or caucus that's not very far
away we've waited this long we can wait
another one